let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
okay an explosive and important
interview with tony babilinski on tucker
carlson last night he's a former hunter
biden
uh business associate who has now come
out as a whistleblower
exposing the corruption he came out
after the laptop story to confirm
that the emails there are real there was
quite a lot
uh in this interview we can't play all
of it obviously but here's i think
the headline listen to this i'm thinking
about
the biden family like how are they doing
this
i know joe decided not to run in 2016
but what if he ran
in the future aren't they taking
political risk or headline risk
and i remember looking at jim biden and
saying how are you guys
getting away with this like or aren't
you concerned
and he sort of looked at me and he
laughed a little bit and said
plausible deniability he said that out
loud
uh yes he said it directly to me
one-on-one in a cabana at the peninsula
hotel
after about a you know hour and a half
two hour meeting with me
asking out of concern how are you guys
doing this aren't you concerned that
you're going to put your brother's
future presidential campaign at risk um
you know
the chinese the stuff that you guys have
been doing already in 2015 and 2016
around the world
and uh i just can almost picture his
face where he sort of chuckles and says
you know plausible deniability so he
said this is a man who's been drafting
off his brother's political career for
almost 50 years
he said to your face essentially we're
lying about it
anyone watching this interview can look
up what plausible deniability means
and the definition's very distinct of
course you know i call that the headline
but it's only the headline if you're an
honest person
who cares about what's really happening
in the world
and you want to talk about actual news
that matters that then it's then it's a
headline
as far as our media is concerned there
was no headline from that interview
because the interview never happened
instead i woke up this morning and uh
you know the headline that i saw the
media talking about
was trump had a rally i guess in omaha
and some people had trouble getting home
from the rally because there was a
problem with the shuttle buses
and so there's some people that were
very cold outside trying to get back
from the rally
and this is a this is this is headline
news more than
more than what we just heard evidence of
real corruption
in the biden family no people having
trouble on a shuttle bus getting back
from a trump rally which by the way
is trump's fault because donald trump as
the president united states and the and
the presidential candidate
is supposed to be working out the
logistics of getting people to and from
he's supposed to be the one on the phone
you know calling the bus company
i'm sure that's what joe biden does
right no in fact well joe biden doesn't
have to as we move on to number two here
nice transition because joe biden
doesn't have to worry about bus
buses to his rallies because he could
fit everybody in his rally into like a
honda accord
um here's uh he had a rally in georgia
if you can even call it that here's the
footage
it's the saddest thing i've ever seen in
my life am i supposed to be depressed
when i see a politician's rally is that
is that the
the vibe that joe biden's going for
because that's how i feel
and if he's going for that he absolutely
nails it
brilliantly so you can take a look at
this there he is walking down the steps
there's the rally
uh you see all the people they're in
they've got these circles
painted on the ground and they all stay
in their circle
and there's a fire pit in the middle for
some reason
honestly if i saw this without any
context at all
i would assume that it's some weird cult
thing you must stay in the circle
the circle must not not be breached i
would assume it's something like that
people of the circle i would just maybe
i'd guess it would be the name of the
cult i don't know
um and i i guess i wouldn't be too far
off actually in reality
it is a little bit of a weird cult thing
now people ask if you know you see these
things and this is at all
a lot of biden's rallies where they got
the circles and everybody has to stay in
the circle
and there's you know there's 14 people
at the rally they're all in their little
circle
and the question is why do you need the
circles on the ground you spread the
chairs out why do you need to put
circles around it
and uh well there's two reasons for it
number one this is this is virtue
signaling this is signaling see but
we're we're taking
we are unlike donald trump we're taking
chronovirus very seriously
look we spray painted circles on the
ground that's how seriously we take it
but also it's supposed to be an excuse
for the low turnout
and what they're doing is they're
advertising anyone who sees it they're
saying you see we could only fit so many
people in the circles we only had look
we only had 12 circles to go even though
we spray painted them we could have but
you know we had we only had enough spray
paint for 12 circles that's why there's
only 12 people
there's there's 6 000 other people that
wanted them to come but they couldn't
that's why they make the circles there
okay number three amy coney barrett has
only been a supreme court justice for a
day but already she's generating
controversy
um here's the headline in the hill
justice amy coney barrett
to use supreme court chambers formerly
occupied by the late ruth bader ginsburg
so she's going to be in rbg's chambers
and if you read comments on social media
a fair number of people
are upset about this because of course
it's horribly offensive for her to use
the great rbg's chambers how dare she
how dare she use
now i'm not really sure what she's
supposed to do they'll i assume they
only have so many
like they've got one for each justice
so of course she's what are they gonna
do build her new chambers and then
keep the mummified remains of rbg and
her old
seal it you know like a like a pyramid
egyptian style is that
is that what they want in fact i think
unironically the left would expect that
because we've also heard that um not
only has amy coney barrett stolen
uh rbg's spot on the supreme court now
she steals her offices
she's also stolen initials this is
something you see a lot that
when we call amy coney barrett acb we
shouldn't do that
because we only do that for rbg
rbg invented initials no one had
initials before her
how dare acb steal those
what a leech appropriating um number
four
pizza hut is the latest fast food joint
to end racism so this is also pretty big
news i'd say
uh you know i think any time racism is
ended
i i think it's something we should pay
attention to and racism has ended every
single day by by another corporation
and then it starts up again and then so
someone else has to come and end it
again so it's this constant like a
whack-a-mole sort of thing
but uh here's the daily wires pizza hut
has teamed up with a non-profit social
enterprise developing guidelines to
quote
correct implied and overt forms of bias
and privilege
in teaching methods and classroom
materials the 46-page training manual is
advertised as an introduction to
anti-racist
pedagogy pedagogy guiding
guiding teachers who seek to increase
their personal awareness on the subject
leading experts in the anti-bias
anti-racist
field are said to have informed the
content which encourages educators to
incorporate
those visions into lesson plans okay
well that's good um
because you know when i think of pizza
hut
the first thing i think is this is a
company
whose primary goal is to correct implied
and over
overt forms of bias and privilege
that's the first thing i think of when i
think of pizza
and you know it might really be because
i certainly don't think of pizza for
pizza hut
um i mean if you if you like
cart if you like to have tomato sauce on
aren't on cardboard
with old cheese on top if that's your
thing then pizza hut certainly is
the way to go all right let's go to
number five and probably we've done a
lot of big story probably the biggest
story
of you know the year kim kardashian
turned 40.
so happy birthday to her even though i
canceled birthdays i'll make an
exception kim kardashian she can have
one
because she's famous and rich and
important so obviously they are
exceptions
a lot of people are upset about her
social media posts relating to her
birthday
and this is what she posted let's go
through this
so on twitter she says 40 and feeling so
humbled and blessed
this is not there's not a single day
that i take for granted especially
during these times when we are all
reminded of the things that truly matter
and there she is posing with her uh with
her friends
for my birthday party this year i
couldn't think of a better way to spend
it than with some of my the people who
have helped shape me into the woman i am
today
before covid i don't think any of us
truly appreciated what a simple luxury
was to be able to travel and be together
with family and friends in a safe
environment after two weeks of multiple
health screens and asking everyone to
quarantine
i surprised my closest inner circle with
a trip to a private island where we
could pretend things were normal just
for a brief moment in time
we danced rode bikes swam near wales
kayaked watched a movie on the beach and
so much more
i realized that for most people this is
something that is so far out of reach
right now
so in moments like these i am humbly
reminded of how privileged my life is
i like how she says this is so far out
of reach right now
like for most of us it's yeah you know i
can't really swing the
the two-week trip to the private island
this year can't really do it
uh you know i had to cut back on a few
things had to cut out the private island
trip
so i can keep three or four of my
mansions i was kind of had to choose
um now a couple things here number one
a lot of this is my own personal health
routine uh you know
i i dance and swim at the whales three
times a week it's just a normal fitness
thing i thought everybody did that
number two my only real problem when i
see this
is the bit about watching a movie on the
beach
that seems like the kind of thing you do
for the social media picture
but otherwise why would you i can't
think of a of a worse place to watch
obviously the acoustics are are not good
or non-existent
you're on the beach you've got the waves
crashing you're sitting in the sand
what's the advantage of watching a movie
on the beach as opposed to just going
into your house
i assume she has a house with a home
theater with a with a really nice home
theater system
so if i went to kim kardashian's
birthday party
which i doubt i'd be invited but if i
was i would attend and she said we're
gonna watch a movie i'd be excited
thinking oh we're gonna go watch it on a
you know
100 foot whatever and then she said oh
no we're gonna watch it on tv on the
beach i'd be i'd be pretty upset about
that
most people though are upset i guess
this this
post caused controversy because she's
rich
and she can do this and how dare she
flaunt it um that's not the part that
upsets me personally i uh
you know i tend to think if you're rich
enough
if i was rich enough i'd go on a private
island too so we can't blame her for
that
although we can't blame her for
celebrating a birthday in general
because has has been established
birthdays are canceled well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt walsh
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content